サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今月のテーマについていくらか話したいと思っています
今日はあまり難しい内容ではありません
心をどうやってクリアにするのかという
簡単なお釈迦様が説かれた方法なんです
今日は特別専門用語として
このダンマサマーディというね
ダンマは法 サマーディっていうのはね
サマーディ そのまま日本語でもカタカナ使って用語使ってますからね
禅定三昧ということですね
で それにつなげてもう一つ単語がありますけど
チッタサマーディ 両方紹介しますけど
意味としては この曖昧のない
優柔不断のない生き方
どのように発見するのかと
ずっと一つの経典に基づいて今日の講演を進めたいと思います
で まず生き方って何でしょうかと
勉強 仕事 子育てなどで忙しい時は気にしない課題ですね
我々はどのように生きるべきかということは
なかなか忙しい時はそんなに頭で考えることはしないんです
忙しいと言ったっても
大体この三つのカテゴリーばっかりですからね
勉強か仕事か子育てとかね
そんなカテゴリーですけどね
暇でやることは少なくなると気になりますね
で 自分には暇が出てきて
やることが少なくなってくると
どうしようか どんな風に生きればいいかということは
その時々で気にしますし
とは言っても 子供の頃から死まで
死ぬまで一貫しているのは自分の生き方なんですね
私たちは全然もう関係ないと思ってるんだけど
やっぱり生まれてから死ぬまで生きているんだから
その生き方は一番大事なんですね
生きている上で何かやるだけの話なんですね
だから私たちはこの大事なことを忘れて
ただたまたま生きているんだから
やっていることだけ大事にするんですね
なんか言ってるようにね
なんか生きているんだから食べるんだで
食べるために生きているんだような話なんですね
食べるために生きるっていうことはね
ちょっとおかしいんですけどね
はい そういうわけで まあ仕事やら子育てやら
それは私たちはしっかりやらなくちゃいけないんだそうと思っていてね
で 生き方は まあそれはまあ宗教が暇つぶしに喋ってるでは喋ってることではないかなと思ったりもしますね
生き方は金にならない無駄なことだと思っているので
宗教の管轄になっています
正直な話なんですね 皆様認めたくないんですけど
私から見れば結局はそれでしょうと
金にならない話にはならないという
だから生き方を正したんだからって
それで金になるということですね
聞くのは ですから それは宗教の管轄だと
しかし これ 宗教の管轄にしてみれば大きな問題ですよ
宗教っていうのは何か信仰することから始まるんですね
何かを信じなくていけないんですね
まず 何か信じると言ったところで
あなた何を信じていますか？とかね
まあもうもう今皆様もキリスト教になっていると思いますけど
あなたは神を信じていますか？とかね
まあ聞かれることであると思いますけど
うーん 私に聞いてくれないんですよ
私はカエルさんを信じますとかね
なんか言いたいと答えまで用意してるんですけどね
で まあ信仰になってくると
まあ一必要だと思っている人々はいるんですね
まあ我々の中にもいますね
信仰は必要ですと いらないと
信仰なんかは そういう人々もいる
信仰って疑問だなと いろいろありまして
ちょっとわからない 疑問やと思う人もいる
それから信仰に反対だと
何も信じる必要ありませんと反対を言う人々もいる
またいるんですね  5番目
まあ信仰っていうのはもう誰でも同じことを言ってますよと
で 神社の神様を信じても
西洋の神々を信じても
インドの神を信じなくても
まあまあ同じごっちゃだから同じやと
さて  6番目のグループの方々は
この信仰なんかは理解できないんだと
そういうふうに反応が出てくるんですね
それで そういう方々にそれなりの理由もあるでしょうと思います
で 皆様方はどんなカテゴリーに入るのかと考えてみてください
で  2つとも椅子あるかもしれませんし
あるいはこの 6つに入らない方々がいるならば
それもおっしゃった方がいいと思います
私の勉強のために 私はこの 6つにも入りませんよと
私は個人的に言えば この 2 3 4 なんですね
いわゆるいらない これって疑問ばっかしで
それから反対と はい なんで信仰は入れてというと
宗教になってくると信仰があって
それからもうこういうふうに生きてみなさいよと言ってくれるんですね
問題は その信仰がどうなっているのかと
信じることがそれ合ってるない
合ってるかないかなんですね
どのように生きるべきかと決めることはそれでできなくなっちゃうんです
信仰は必要やと思う人は
自分を信仰する組織で言われる通りに生きてみると
いらないと思っている人にとっては
どうすればいいかとわからなくなっちゃうし
そういうわけで 一番大事なことはわからなくなっているんですよ
仕事があったってもね
生き方が仕事より大事なんですね
勉強 今勉強中だと言ったっても
人間として生きることはまず大事であって
その上で勉強しているんですね
だから それをわからないということは困ったもんですね
また 宗教になってくると
それで終わらないんですね
宗教は必ず対立します
仲が悪いんです 同一宗教はありません
この世の中で 他宗教と違うところを徹底的にハイライトします
一つ その宗教組織が他の宗教組織とどこが違います
そればっかしいわゆる喧嘩するためのポイントばっかしもうあげてるんですね
これでこれで仲良くできるんじゃないという話はまずしないんです
イスラム教とキリスト教はね
信奉者も行って 我々はどこで似ているんですか？どこで兄弟として手を繋いで生きることできるのかということは絶対しません
コーランだけ真理ですから
もう捨てなさいと あなた方の考え方はすべて捨てなさいとはっきり言っちゃうんですね
だからキリスト教も同じことで
同じ宗教でも宗派を作って分かれて対立します
これ なおさらまずいんですよ
宗教に宗派があるんですね
仏教にもありますね お釈迦様は宗教は説かれなかったんだから
もう問題にならないんだけど
お釈迦様の教えを宗教にしちゃったんですね
これも宗教ですよと 信じるものですよと
拝むものですよ それでいろんな宗派に分かれて
お互いに喧嘩することになっているんですね
だから 現代の日本にある仏教宗派を見ても
なんか何の共通点もないんですね
ちょっと試しに禅宗と日蓮宗を比較してみてください
何か似ているところはあるのかと
何もないんです じゃあ日蓮宗と
もう念仏宗とは言わないね
浄土宗ですね 似ていますかと
全く似ていないんですね
似ているところ 私を呼んで仏教の話
講演法話させたんだからといってお寺を追い出しますからね
面白いでしょう 仏教の話をすると
そのお寺を破門されます
日本の宗派仏教ではブッダのことを言うなよと
で うちの祖師様の話をしなさいという話なんです
ブッダをゴミ箱に捨ててるんです
だからこのキリスト教でも同じ宗派がありまして
イスラム教でも宗派がありまして
イスラム教の宗派はお互いすごく仲がいいんです
ちゃんと殺し合ってます
で みんなお互いやって終わってもらえばね
世界平和ですけどね 早くやれと言いたいんだけど
スンニ派と何とか派とかね
まあキリスト教はもうやめたんですね
昔殺し合いやっていたんですけどね
自由な人は宗教を選ぶことになるとまた困ります
そういうわけで 私は生き方を知りたい
では 宗教のお世話になりますと言っても
どうやって宗教選ぶんですかね
これすごいお互い喧嘩する
もう悪魔のグループみたいなもんなんですね
はい それだけじゃなくて
生き方も対立することになります
だって 各宗教はお互い対立する場合は
各宗教が語る生き方も対立するでしょう
各宗派がお互い対立しているんだから
同じ宗教の中で そうすると
各宗教が語る生き方がまた対立するんですね
皆様が知っている日本の例を出せば
一部が南無妙法蓮華経と言えばすべて終わりやと言うし
一部は南無阿弥陀と言えばすべて終了やと言ったりもするし
どちら言えばいいんですかね
各宗教が示す生き方 修行の仕方
目指す目的などは異なります
日蓮系は死んでからどこに行くかわかりませんだけど
まあ浄土系はね 一応極楽道というところが設定してありますけど
日蓮宗は地獄でしょうか
よくわからないんですね
まあ行く道がありませんだけどね
で まあ何か言ってるでしょうね
そこで目指す目的とするところが違っちゃうと
そちらに行く道も修行方法も変わっていくんです
じゃあ現代人がやってみてくださいと
笑 だから現代人の宗教離れっていうのは
このまさにその通りのことなんですね
で 自由な人間に理性のある人間に語ることはできないんです
宗教に だから人間が頭が悪くて
理解能力がなくて バカでアホで
言うことは何でも信じる人間でなければいけません
そういうことでまあ 宗教離れということになっているんですね
それは決して悪い現象ではないと思います
一つの宗教で善とするものは
他の宗教で悪だと解く場合も多いんです
これはあまりいい例じゃないんだけど
豚肉を食べれば地獄に落ちるという人もいるし
牛肉を食べればもう大変地獄に落ちるという人もいますからね
何ですかねと聞きたいんだけど
ユダヤ教なんかではね
パンを作る場合はこの酵母を使わないんですね
なんかいろいろあります
だから ある宗教で善ということがある宗教で悪になったりもします
で そういうことで現代宗教を取り出して説明すると
まあ私がクタクタ批判を受けますからね
別に怖いわけじゃないんだけどね
余計なことだからやめましょうよと思ったんです
だからまあどうせ世の中無知な人の方がもうものすごい断然多いんだから
まあ信仰すればよろしいし
すごい数少ない理性の人々に別なことを喋りましょうと
ですから この皆様にも今キリスト教になっているんだからね
立ち触る内容にと あの
何でしたっけ お釈迦様の時代の宗教だけ例に出して説明します
しかし 覚悟して言うことですが
お釈迦様の時代の宗教っていうのは結構あの
厳しいというかね 哲学的にはレベル高いんです
はい それにアクセスする前に
お釈迦様が大体何でもすごく見事にまとめて集約するんです
だから人類の中にある善と悪はどのようにどのようなものであるべきかと信仰なし
まとめてみたんです これはあの
10種類あるんですね
11はありませんし あの９で終わることでもないんで
お釈迦様に言われたらそれで終わりです
10種類あるんです  1 パーナーティパート殺生
2 アディナーダーナ盗み
簡単に訳すとまた面倒くさい
で サンカーミーすみチャーチャラン
ジャインですね 四ムサーワーダン
これ嘘ですね 五ピスナーワーチャン
これ噂 六パルサーワーチャ
粗悪語 これきつい言葉
七サンパップラパン 無駄話
八アビジャン これ異常欲
まあ強強欲と言うんですか
そんな感じですね 九ビャーパーダン
これ瞋恚 異常怒りと理解しても構いません
十番目ミッチャーディッティ
見方が間違っている ものの見方
邪見と言うんですね これが悪です
十一番ありません 九で終わることがないんです
これはもう決まってる
十悪で そちらの反対は十善になるんです
まあ簡単ですからね 殺生しないこと
盗まないこと で 不邪淫
邪まなことをしない で
嘘つかない 真理を語る
そんな感じで噂言わない
で 粗悪語をやめて優しい言葉を語る
それから無駄話をやめて
意味のある言葉 役に立つ言葉を語る
それから異常欲があっても
異常欲をやめる 常識範囲で欲をコントロールする
怒りはあるんだけど 常識の範囲で怒りを制御する
それからものの見方をしっかりするということが十善なんですね
それでお釈迦様が次にこう言うんです
私はこれ まあそういう軽々しく言ってるわけじゃないんだと
これ長い経典ですよ 一項目取り上げて
私はこれを全部知り尽くしてるんだよと
だからお釈迦様はこの知り尽くす方法っていうのは
この心の働きを知ってるんですね
だからアメリカ人であろうが
インド人であろうが 中国人であろうが
人間ですよ 人間の心の働き方は決まってるんです
他の生命も心を持ってるんですね
だから心はどのように働くかっていうこと
決まってもう学んだ方々は知ってるんですね
こういうパターンで心が働くんだよと
で その中から取り上げてるんですね
悪はこれで 善はこれであると
だから一 これらを知っている
例えば殺生とは何ぞやと
知り尽くしてるんだと
それで殺生すればどのように結果を受けますかと
例えば皆様わからないでしょ？なんで殺生が悪いんでしょうかねとかね
なんで生命殺したら悪い結果になるのかと
そのカラクリを知らないんですね
お釈迦様が心はどんな風に変化して
どんな風になるのかと
それは見事に知ってるんです
一応わかりやすくして言います
で 殺生したら相手が死ぬだけじゃなくて
殺生した私の心が変わるんですね
心に何かのエネルギーがフィードバックになっちゃうんですね
これはどうにもならないんです
忘れることはできません
頭の上で忘れちゃってもね
あの心に帰ってきたエネルギーはそのまま残っちゃうんです
残ってから それから心の変化にそれ影響を与えるんです
例えば川の上でボートの上に立って
もう力いっぱいボールを投げるとどうなるんですか？
小さなボートだったらね
ボートは動くでしょ 逆方向に
これはどうしようもないんです
そのように心が何かやっちゃうと
そのやったことから何かエネルギーがフィードバックされちゃって
心の回転の流れがね ちょっと変わってしまいます
はい それでどのような殺生はどのような結果出しますかということを明確にお釈迦様は知っています
三 どのように どのようにそれらを犯したら死後地獄に落ちるのか
それも知っています それで
殺生した だからあんた地獄という風に
いい加減な考えは仏教でないんです
他の宗教でそう言ってる場合ありますからね
殺すなかれと言ってるんだけど
すごい曖昧 いい加減なんですね
イスラム教でも殺すなかれと言ってますけど
イスラム人を殺すなかれ
殺された人はイスラム教
アッラー神を信仰していないならば
別に大したことはない
だからそれでいいんですかね
それで昔 バラモン人も同じことを言っていたんですよ
インドで 人を殺しても
だって戦争がずっとしょっちゅうあったんだから
もうインドっていうのは国がたくさんまとめてできたんだから
それ 国同士で戦争しちゃうんですね
だから人を殺されるんですよ
それでこのバラモン人が人を殺しても大した罪にならないんだけど
いかなる場合でもバラモン人を殺したらもう重罪で
もう償う方法はありませんと
随分勝手なこと 宗教家がバラモン人だから
自分を殺したら罪が多いんだと
そんないい加減なことはお釈迦様は言いません
お釈迦様はまあ誰か殺したんだからといって
すぐ地獄に落ちるということはないんだけど
殺生の仕方によって確実に死後地獄に落ちる場合もあります
地獄に そんなのは全部知ってますよと語っているんです
この十悪についても 一項目
一項目挙げて この十項目の反対の行為は善行為というんですね
説明しましたから 次のスライドに飛びます
善悪を認めてもも理解に違いがある
って書いてある これでお釈迦様はなんでこの善と悪の項目
20項目設定したんですかというと
これはこのフリー自由で考える人々のためなんです
宗教に足が引っ張らないようでないようにと
信仰があってもなくても
誰にでも あ これならやっぱり悪でしょう
これなら善でしょうと
誰にでも賛成できるものなんです
しかし これ完璧なリストなんです
まともな人間に否定できません
例えばものの見方が間違ったら構いませんよと言える？言えないでしょう
ものの見方が正しくなければあかんだからね
まあ 1 日中無駄話した方がいいやと言えますかね
そうじゃないでしょう
やっぱり喋ることは意味があって
役に立つものだったらもっとベターだよということは誰でも思っていることです
はい それでこの10項目設定して
なぜ 20項目ですね 重善重悪ですね
設定してから これは他の宗教にも当てはめてみるんですね
当てはめちゃうと 各宗教の人々はそれにも反対できなくなるんです
仏陀の教えは見てませんだけど
まあ重善重悪はまあだってそうでしょうということにしてしまっちゃうんです
だから誰だって認めること
そこはかなりあの大乗仏教がもう自分の尾っぽ自分で踏んで痛い痛いと言ってるんだから
ずいぶん勘違いしているんですね
大菩薩戒といって この十悪をしないことで決めちゃうんですね
当たり前のことをどうやって菩薩戒になるんですかね
もっと上のことを頑張りなさいと言いたいんだけど
これは宗教があってもなくても
まともな人間なら守る項目なんですね
だから上座部仏教と違って
我ら偉い人間だから菩薩戒として菩薩戒守ってるんだと
まあ病院に行けということなんです
で 現代のお坊様方に悪口を言ってるわけじゃなくて
この大乗仏教を作った中国の偉い連中とかね
昔のね インドのいた頭イカれた人々とかね
そういう連中に言ってるんですけどね
はい これでこの経典が始まる前に面白いエピソードがあるんです
で インドにあったどんな宗教も
重善重悪に対しては反対と立ち上がれないんです
立ち上がれないんです
そこで無神論者たちがインドにいましたよ
現代だけじゃないんです
唯物論もありました しかし
一般的にこの生き方として
まあ反対ということはなかったようですね
そこである一部の宗教家がこのこう言うんですね
例えば殺生したならば
この世で不幸に陥るんだと
厳然的に目の前で殺したらあなたに罰が当たると
来世のことは言わない
この世で だからお釈迦様はこの人々の言い方はちょっとおかしいんだと
殺生したら不幸になる
この世で必ずも目の当たりにして不幸になると
あれは勘違いやと言って例を出すんです
まあ時々いるんだと このインドで
インドでね お釈迦様と対話したのは在家のポータリアという在家の人なんですね
この在家の人と対話して
あんたは見たことあるでしょ
時々ものすごい豪華で贅沢三昧で
美味しいものを食べて遊んで
もう贅沢三昧で生きてる人々いるでしょうにと
なんでこの人はこんなに豊かになったのかと聞いたら
その人は 軍隊を持って隣の国に行って
結構戦争をして人を殺して帰りましたと
そこで王様が大喜びでボードを治めてきたんだから
国に対して反対していて
みんな殺してきたんだからね
すごく喜んでいっぱいご褒美を財産をあげているんだと
で ポータリアに聞くんで
あんたそういうケース見たことないの？はい
見たことありますよと
だからあの宗教が言ってることはちょっと合ってないでしょうにと
ある人が殺生して その結果もう死に物狂いになっているんですね
人殺して だから殺生したら不幸になるということは
こんなに簡単に説明できる甘い話じゃないんだよと
それであんた見たことがあるでしょうにと
時々人を捕まって髪の毛を剃って
青い青いじゃない 赤い花輪を首にかけて
頭にも赤い花の冠をかぶさせて
両手を結んで鞭で打ちながら打ち首に持っていくんですね
もう太鼓を叩きながら鞭で打ちながら
行って あの人を首を切る場所に連れて行って
そこでチョキンと首を切っちゃう
そういうふうに目の前で不幸に陥って
罰が当たっている人も見たことあります
ありましょうと あれ 調べたらどうなるかといったら
この人は 国王に対して対立して
王様の気に入りの人を殺しちゃったと
これで処刑になっているんですね
これで一人が人を殺して
すごい金持ちになっちゃって
一人が人を殺してもう処刑になっていると
だから殺生したらすぐこの場で罰が当たるということを言うなよと
そんな話じゃありませんよと
だから面白かったのは
私個人的には お釈迦様がこの世の中でどう生きているのか
人間の これもちゃんと観察しているんですね
同じ項目をどんどんいくんですよ
盗みにいくんです ある人がすごい金持ちでいるんだと
なんであと調べたら この人は隣の国に行って
もう戦いに行って その国の財産
財産を全部奪って帰ってきたんだと
それで王様が喜んじゃって
昔は戦争したら一般人の財産も盗んで帰るんだからね
ものすごい豊かにしてあげているんだと
それ一人 もう一人が調べたらもう処刑に連れて行くんですね
鞭で打たれながら なぜかというと
調べたら この人は王様の気に入りの人の家に入って泥棒やっちゃったと
だからもう大量に盗むした人
盗んだ人が戦争に行ってね
豊かになったりして ちょっとした泥棒をやった人が処刑になったりするんだよと
そういうわけで まあいい加減
無批判的に言ってはならないということですね
お釈迦様が言うのは しかし
現実を見るとそうとも限らない
私は具体的に説明します
したがって 次のポイント
ある宗教家がこう語る
殺生したら自覚 あるいは殺生したらもう目の当たりに不幸になる
でも現状を調べたらそうじゃないでしょ
それでポーティアさんに聞くんですね
そうすると その宗教家が本当のことを言ってますかと
嘘を言っていることにならない
そうですね お釈迦様は
そうすると その宗教家たちが嘘を言っているんだと
あのね あんた この嘘をついている宗教家がちゃんと戒律を守っていると思う
ちょっとそう思いませんよと
そこでその人々の意見
見解が正しいと思う いえ
正しくない ですから邪見でしょうにと
ちょっと微妙な理論ですよ
それで邪見を持つ人を信じる必要ありますかと
こうやってきれいさっぱり宗教崩れるんです
どんな宗教も調べると正しいことを語ってないんです
邪見なんです はい これがパーリ語でこういう論理の組み立てなんですけど
一応日本語訳します ヨーコウチパーナーパーナマティマティパーテーティ
誰かが殺生するならば
サッボーソー そのすべての人々ディッテーワダンメー
この世でドゥッカンドーマナッサンパティサンヴェーディエッティ
この世で苦しみに悩み
破目になりますよと 悩み苦しむことになりますよ
すべての人々は だから殺生するすべてがというところで
論理理論崩れているんです
殺生する一部なんです
しかし 勘違いしないでください
殺生して幸せになるわけじゃないんです
国のために行って人を殺したら
こちらでやくなんとか神社でね
もう拝んでくれるかもしれません
だけど地獄に落ちることはもう避けられませんよ
それにもそれなりのまあ順番があります
そのように言ってしまったら
サッチャンワーテーアーハンスムサーワー
彼らが本当のことを言ってますか？嘘を言ってますかと
それ調べたところで嘘を言っているんです
ムサーバンテ 嘘を言ってますよ
尊師 イエパナテトゥッチャンムサーウィラパンってお釈迦様が聞くんです
もし誰かがトゥッチャン空っぽの嘘を言ってるんだったら
調べようともしないで勝手なことを言うならば
シーラバンターテ 彼らが本当に道徳を守っていると思う？あるいはドゥッシーラ
破壊の戒律を守ってない人間かと言ったら
ドゥッシーラバンテ シーラがないんだよと答えるんですね
イエパナテドゥッシーラ
パーパダンマ ミッチャーパティパンナ
ワーテーサンマパティパンナ
誰かが道徳も守らないし
頭も悪いし 変なことを言うし
だから彼らが正しく修行すると言えるか
いえ ちょっと正しく修行するとは言いづらいんですよと答えるんですね
ミッチャーパティパンナ
間違ってますよと 修行まで
イエパナテーミッチャーパティパンナ
ミッチャーディッティカーワーテーサンマディッティカー
もし間違った修行するならば
彼らの見解 ものの見方が正見ですか？邪見ですかと
修行を間違っているのだったら邪見ですよと答えが来るんですね
それでお釈迦様は結論を出すんです
イエパナテーミッチャーディッティカー
カッランヌテースパシーディスンと
もし邪見だったらね 別に信仰しなくてもいいんじゃないと
だから宗教に対する ああ
すごいことやと 宗教は尊敬しなくてということは
お釈迦様は何のことなくする
そんな気にしなくてもいいやと
これはお釈迦様が使った論理の方法で
では インド哲学 宗教哲学をちょっと学んでみましょう
エーコーサッテーワンワーディーエーワンディッティ
ナッティディンナン ナッティイッタン
ナッティウタン ナッティスカタドッカターナン
カンマナン ファランヴィパコー
ナッティアンローコー
ナッティパローローコー
ナッティマター ナッティピター
ナッティサッテー ウパパーティカー
ナッティローケー サマナバーフマナ
サммаガター サッマーパティパンナー
イエー マンチャローカン
パランチャローカン サヤンアビニャン
サッチカッガーパウェデンティーという一つの宗教です
この場合も インドにバラバラバラバラある宗教をお釈迦様が学問的にしっかりとまとめてまとめて経典に残されているんです
意味なんですけどね これは仏教では１０種類の邪見とダサワットカサンマディッティと言われている項目なんです
で 意味も書いてますけど
次に出しますけど で 一応ここで見てみるならば
ポインター開いてないね
うん 一行目ね ナッティディンナンという言葉があります
一行目 ナッティディンナン
ディンナンというのはあげる与えることですね
布施ですね それで何の意味もないんだと
ナッティイッタンというのは
この宗教的なブラマン教の布施なんですね
インドの負担というのは
もうまたこのをあげながら踊りながらやっているというと
大げさな 宗教儀式なんですね
二行目ですね 今説明するのは
ナッティスカルドゥッカターナンカムマナンパランヴィパッコ
善行為 悪行為に何の結果もありませんと言うんです
そこで三行目後半でナッティアヤンローコ
この世というものはないんだと
いわゆる生命の存在も否定するんです
次にナッティパラローコ
あのこの世なければ あの世もないんだからね
あの世というものもありませんよと
それからナッティマータ
母はいませんと なんか母いませんって何でしょうかね
これ深い意味があるんですよ
生命の存在を認めないならば
生命を作る母がいるわけじゃないんです
だからはっきり言えば
親孝行しても何の意味もない
こんなもともと存在しないんだよと
で ナッティピタ 父もありませんと
それからナッティサッタオーパパッティカ
これね 宗教で言うんですね
生命はいろいろいるんだよと
例えば我々は母のお腹から生まれる
トカゲやら鳥たちは卵から生まれる
また 生命は体分解して生まれる
体分解して生まれる そういうふうにいろんな生まれ方があるんです
それで神々やら餓鬼やら幽霊やらね
いるかどうかわかりませんだけどね
まあどうでもいいんですけど
そのまま現れるんですね
たった現れる これは化生というんです
生っていうのは化け物の化と生っていうのは生まれる
で 神 天界には化生なんですね
あの天国の天女たちがお産するんじゃないんです
ポツンポツンと神々が現れる
こちら善行した人間が死んじゃったら
そこでポツンと点になって現れる
そういうことは認めない
こういう人々は それからこの世の中で修行して
超越した智慧を得て この世をあの世を理解している人は存在しませんと否定する
有備主論者たちもこの考えを持っている
有備主論でなくても この考えを持っている人々はいるんです
で まあ簡単な日本訳は一布施に結果がない
行いに結果がない 善悪行為に結果がない
この世 あの世はない ない
母なし父なし 継承の生命はなし
超越した智慧を持つ宗教家がなしということになるんです
これらすべて肯定する宗教家もいます
そこで何もない 宗教は何もない
もう嘘 インチキという
もう断言的な この 10種類の邪見得人々もいて
反対にいえいえ違いましょうとお布施したら結果がある
親孝行したらそれなりの結果がある
という人々もいる だから正反対なんですね
10種類の正見と言うんですね
仏教用語ではダサバットとかサンマーディティ
はい これで一つの宗教がわかったんですかね
これ 断言宗教を否定する宗教なんです
この教えを教えた人々も
もう行者として生きていたんです
これがちょっと面白い矛盾ですけどね
そこで一部の宗教家がお布施しても何の結果もないよという
一部の宗教家 いえ お布施したら結果がありますよという
一部の宗教家が 行為には全く結果がありません
ただ行為だけ 一部はいえ
行為には結果がある そうやって相反する宗教システム 2つが成り立つんです
またあります エーコーサッタエーワンワーディエーワンディッティ
ある宗教家がこのようなことを語りますよと
かろうとな かろうとカーラーカーレト
これ日本訳は入れてないんです
チンダトーチェーダーペト
パチェトーパチャーペト
あのかろうとっていうのは
する人 行う人がいません
カーラーペトっていうのはさせる人
例えば私に文字を書けます
同時に書かせます そんなのは存在しないと言うんです
難しくないんです あの
ここでこの自我 例えば私が喋ると言ったところで
誰が喋ってますかね？私がなんです
私がいませんと だから私はあなたちょっと喋ってくださいと言うと
私が喋らせさせたんでしょ？喋らせたでしょ
そこで私がというこの自我を否定するんです
自我否定しちゃうとどうなるんですかね
ただ行為だけってことになっちゃうんです
で なんか仏教と似ていると勘違いしないでください
これは仏教と似てないんですよ
因果法則じゃないんだからね
そこでチンダトーチェーダーペト
チンダトーっていうのは
この斬る刀で首を切る人いません
切らせる人もいませんと
パチェトーパチャーペト
人をいじめる 人はいませんと
いじめらせることもできませんと
ショーチェートショーチャイペート
悩む人もいませんし 悩ませることもできません
キレマトウキレマ キレマっていうのは
このまた同じいじめなんですけど
かなりひどい 肉体的にいじめることもできないし
いじめらせることもできない
パンダティっていうのはもっとひどいことをするんですね
それからパーナーパーナマティパーというと
殺傷する人はいません
盗む人はいません サンディチンダト
サンディチンダタっていうのは
このハイウェイロバー
どこかで人々 国から国へ行く
このハイウェイありますね
昔もありましたから インドでもね
そういうところで待ち構えて泥棒する
ニッローパンハラトっていうのは
泥棒グループが村を狙って村に行って
村を丸ごと盗んで持っていく
そんなのはいませんと
エーカーガーリカンっていうのは
これ盗みの仕方ですね
インドの泥棒グループがある一軒家を狙って
みんな殺して全財産持っていく
一軒しか盗まない そういう感じ
パリパンテティッタトっていうのは
小さな小さな道路で隠れていて盗む人
そんなのはいませんと
パラダーランガッチャと
他人の奥さんに行く人
嘘を言う人いませんと
これで最終的に何言うかというと
我々は何かいろいろなことをやっても
過労等な刈り入れでパパン
このやる人が罪を犯してないんだと
だって自我がないんだからね
これはブラフマン教に対する反宗教なんです
魂があって こいつが全部やってるんだよと
それで面倒くさいんだから魂がないと
そうすると私が人を殺したって
別に誰が殺したわけじゃないんだから罪はないんだと
心配しなさいと そこで一口言うんですよ
徹底的に言うんです クラパリヤンテーナ
チェーピチャッケン ヨーイミッサーパタウィア
パーネ エーカン マンサカラン
エーカン マンサプンジャン
カレーヤ ナッティ タトー
ニダーナン パパン  クラパリヤンタっていうのはよくわからない武器なんですけど
まあ刀でも何でもいいんだけど
ひどい武器を持って この地球上の生命を全部殺しちゃって
もう肉の山を作るんだと
殺して殺して殺しても捨てる
それでも死体の山が現れるでしょうね
そんなこと言ったっても何の罪もないんだよと
生命は全滅したっても罪はありませんと
ダッキナン チェーピ ガンガーヤン
ティーラン ガッチャイア
ハナントー ガーテントー
チンダントー チェーダーペント
パッチャントー パチャーペント
ナッティ タトー ニダーナン
パパン まあこれガンジス川はインド人に対してはね
聖なる川だから で まあ北から南へ南へ下りなくちゃあかんですね
これで 北ヒマラヤ山脈にいる住んでいる人が修行だと思って下りるんです
南に下りるんだけど この人は殺して殺して殺していったってもね
何の罪もないんだよと
ウッタリン チェーパ ガンガーヤン
ティーラン ガッチャイア
ダダントー ダダーペント
そこで南からヒマラヤまで行く
ある人がどのように行くと
お布施をしながら みんなにもお布施をしなさいと言いながら
修行をしながら 良いことをしながら
修行の旅をするんだと
別に何の得にもなりませんよと
善もないし悪もないんだよと
ダーネーナ ダメーネ サンゲネーナ
サッチャワッジェーナ
ナッティ プンニャン お布施すること
自己を自己戒める こと
それから真理を語ることで
何の善行為にもなりませんよと
何の結果もありません
ナッティプンヤサーでも徳はありませんよと
バカなことをしただけ
自己戒めてという そこでこう断言的に肯定する宗教もあります
今まで言った文章の反対
エワンサッタエワンワーディエワンディティ
かろうと変わらぬと 珍道中というと
やっぱりする人がいますよと
させる人がいますよと
だから悪行為に罪がある
善行為には徳があると
全く反対のことを言う
一人があのね 人殺したっても
誰も誰が誰が殺したことってないんだから
罪がないんだよと もう一人が
いやいや あなたがその人を殺したんだから
あなたに罪がありますよという
正反対でしょ だからインドの宗教
結構ややこしいんですよ
このように相反する様々な宗教の教えを聞いたコーリヤ国のパータリ孤児が悩むことになりました
はい エピソードに戻ります
このパータリという孤児がお釈迦様に会ってこういう質問をしたんです
お釈迦様は詐欺 インチキ
マジック知ってますか？と
お釈迦様にそういう悪い噂が流れてます
お釈迦様はマジシャンであると
だから釈迦様に会ったら
もうみんな仏教徒になっちゃいますよと
あのまじないにかかっちゃいますよと
魔法使いだと 要注意だと
下らない連中は言っていたんですよ
裏で隠れて  お釈迦さんに面と向かって聞くことぐらいは勇気はなかったんですけどね
お釈迦様が魔法使いで
インド人というのはものすごく馬鹿者で
呪文とか信じるんですよ
まあ日本人は信じてないでしょうね
呪文 心眼とかはね あれ
相当インド人がバカもんで
いまだに信じてるんです
オームマニペデメフームとか
チベット仏教でも呪文があるでしょ
般若心経もありますね
ギャーティーギャーティーハラスーギャーティーとかね
あるいはサンスクリット語ではガテーガテーパーラガテーパーラサンガテーボーディスワハというね
行ですけど あれ漢文発音でギャテーガテーガーティーギャーティーギャーティーハラスーギャーティーと言うんですね
あれで重要になるかどうか分かりませんだけどね
信じる人はいますよ そんなのは
だからインドではね なんかなんだらかんだらなんだアブラカダブラかなんとか言ったら
すごい これ魔法使いで
これすごいよと それでこのパータリがパータリっていうんですね
パータリ個人がお釈迦様に聞いちゃったんです
お釈迦様 お釈迦様は魔法とか知ってますか？と
お釈迦様 知ってますよと答えたんです
知ってますよ 答えて やっぱりと
この人は やっぱり ただ
それにお釈迦様はすごい厳しいことを言うんです
むちゃくちゃ人を馬鹿にするんです
こういうたとえ話を持ってくるんです
このコーリヤ国の隣 ウェーサーリ町がありまして
ウェーサーリというのは巨大国ですよ
コーリヤというのは釈尊の隣ですからね
小さな国なんです あんた知ってますから
ランブチュータカという警察いるでしょうにと
特攻隊 特攻隊って言うんですかね
警察のあれ 何て言いますかね
特別機動隊 知ってますよと
その連中がちょっとでも国に悪いことをしちゃうと
なんとかもう法律を犯しちゃうと
行ってみんな殺しちゃいます
これって全部金自分でもらっちゃう
給料はないんです だから政府が認定していますよ
このランブチュータカという機動隊をね
政府認定 これで あのグループとあの村で
ちょっと王様に対してなんかいろいろ言ってるんだいと思ったら
機動隊に連絡行ったら行ってみんな殺しちゃって
全部財産持って自分の家に持ってくるんです
だから誰でも怖い組織なんです
で パーテルに聞くんです
あんた知ってますか？と
そしたら知ってますよ
お釈迦様 で 聞きますけど
あの機動隊があの道徳を守っている
何をおっしゃるんですかと
全く道徳を守ってないんだと
あんた知ってますけど
知ってますよと ほら 見てよと
あなたは この機動ランバ住宅機動隊が恐ろしい存在で
道徳ひとかけらもない
法律を守らないグループだと知ってるでしょ？ということは
パーテル君は道徳ひとかけらもない
とんでもない人間ですねと
それ違いますよと そしたら言ったんだ
あ そう ということで 私が
なんて言いますか 魔法もごまかしも
人を騙すやり方もすべて知っている
知り尽くっているということは
私がやっているという意味じゃないんだよと
ただ能力あるんだから知っている
やり方は 例えばマインドコントロールの仕方と洗脳の仕方を私も知ってますよ
一度もやったことはないんです
私は皆さんマインドコントロールしてないんです
ただ 皆様の判断できる大脳に語っているんです
自分で判断しなさいと
コントロールしたければこんな感じでできます
私には勝てないと思いますよ
だから知っているとやるっていうのは違うんです
で 政府はいろんな組織
日本の政府でもね いろんな組織を作って
国の金をね いろいろごまかしてごまかすシステムばっかり作ってるでしょうに
スタートした時点で私の目はここでこうこうやって金やっちゃいますよと
だから私やるわけないでしょ
知ったっても 最近楽しみが少なくて
それチェックしているんです
はい そこからこの経典を始めて
この宗教 それでこの人はお釈迦様にやられましたからね
お釈迦様は知ってるんだけど
やってないんだと いわゆる人間を魔法で仏教徒にしてないんだと
いうところで お釈迦様
実はね 私にはね ちょっと大きい家があって
その家で私は必要なものをいつでももう 365日用意してあるんだと
もう徹夜して 明かりをあり
寝るところがある 座るところがある
そういうわけで 各地方の宗教家が誰でもいいんだから
あの建物を使ってもよろしいと
私は管理している ポーターリーさんが自分のお金出して
毎日油を持って行って明かりをつける
修行が宗教が来たら 食べるものやら全部用意してあげる
夜寝たければちゃんと寝る場所がある
そこで本人の管理する建物で
個人財産でね 私も説法を聞くんだよと
聞くとあのような説法ばっかしやと
殺しても罪がないと一人が言うし
次の宗教がかけて殺すなかれ
罪がありますよと言うんだよと
困っちゃったと 誰を信じればいいか分からなくなっちゃったと
いう話を釈迦様に言うんです
誰の教えが真理か否か
真理なのか理解できませんでしたと
宗教に対して疑問を抱いたことを疑うこと
まさに正しいのだとお釈迦様は認めます
自我があるという人もいるし
自我がまるっきりない人
虚無主義を語る人もいる
どちらが正しいかわからない
人間が死んじゃったらこれで終わりやという人もいるし
死んじゃったら天国や地獄に行くんだよという人もいるし
あー困った困ったと だから現代と同じ宗教を見ると
もう相反する話ばっかしで
誰が本当のことを言っているかさっぱりわからない
そういう人々さえもわからない
試しに神父さんたちに聞いてみてください
あなた方は本当に知ってますか？と
そうすると聖書にありますからね
神はイエスは神の子だからと
本当に神の子はいつはと聞いてみてください
そしたら いいえ そうですよ
だって奇跡を起こす あれ
本当ですか？と ただ信じてるだけ
あんた神を否定したら地獄に落ちますよと
本当にと 何か証拠あると
皆様に言いますよ だって日本はどちらかというと無宗教国でしょ
無宗の国かどちらかわかりませんだけど
一応いろんな宗教に凝り固まってはないんですね
まあまあ ほとんどキリスト教に偏ってますけど
俺はまあもう格好いいと思ってるんで
だから原始人になっていますけどね
西洋から来たんだからね
やっぱりね  だと言ったっても
別に真剣に信じてるわけじゃないんですね
ただ西洋のものは何でもかっこいいと
もう受け取ってるだけの話で
中身はあまり気にしない
だから NHK は大変ですね
正しいクリスマスのやり方を教えるなくちゃいけない
今日も番組やりましたからね
仏教のマッスルの場合は教えてくれません
はい  余計な話を置いておいて
今もそれぞれいろんな宗教
仏教も同じことですよ
で ミャンマーとかね そちらはテーラワーダ仏教で
テーラワーダ仏教 宗教やってるんですね
その場合は私はどうかなと思いますよ
日本では大乗仏教 宗教やってるだったらどちらでももう五分五分じゃないのかと
宗教というカテゴリーに入っちゃうと大したことないんです
そういうことで まあ互い違いことをばっかしったりしてね
だから知識人は困ります
知識人は結論ができなくて困ります
で お釈迦様がこれを その通りですよと
あなたなんか宗教に疑問を持ってるでしょ
これはもうその通りですと認めてあげるんですね
はい それから今日のポイントやっときました
ダンマサマーディ チッタサマーディ
で 真理を知って実践して落ち着く方法
疑惑を解消する方法 これでどんな宗教が正しいかどうか分からない
死んじゃったら天国に行くか地獄に行くか分からない
ましてあるかもわからないでしょ
正直に考えてください
知ってる 天国あると？知らないでしょうに
地獄があると知っている？知らないでしょうに
でも心配でしょ もし地獄があったらどうしますかね
怖いでしょ なかったら余計に心配したばっかりでしょ
損でしょ だから普通に考えればこうなるんですよ
唯一神様はイエホワですか？アッラーですか？ブラフマですか？ラーマですか？ヴィシュヌですか
シヴァですかとかね アフロマッタですかとかね
どちらですかね そんなの知らないでしょ
で インド人が信仰している
最近ラーマというね あの神話物語に来る王様を信仰しているんで
神だと ただのストーリーですけど
人がある人がワルミキさんが書いた
で だから本当にそうですかとわからないでしょ
もし本当の神がジェホダだったらどうしますかね
アッラーではなくて わからないんですね
はい そういうことで 私たちにはそれを決して考えて結論に達することはできません
宗教同士戦っても戦っても
いつだって物分かりで物分かりで終わっちゃうんです
宗教家が信奉者やっても
互いに喧嘩して終わるんです
私の教えは正しいやと言わんばっかしで
そういうわけで 何が解決策？方法解決策はあるはずなんです
お釈迦様はこれからそれを教えるんです
はい ステップワンでいきましょう
まず 汚れた生き方をやめる
常識的に見ても悪だと言える十悪をやめます
信仰はいらん 宗教はいりません
一応殺しちゃうと いくらなんでもね
盗んじゃうといくらなんでもまずいでしょ
やめましょう 十悪をやめましょうよと
だからお釈迦様が宗教と関係なく
宗教から取り 様々な人間の考え方から取り上げて
心の法則から全十悪十善をちゃんと救出するというかね
フィルタリングして出しているんです
これに宗教は関係ないんです
信仰はいらないんです
信仰はあってもなくても
まあまるっきり無駄 非論者であっても
殺すことはやめましょうよと
生命に対して殺生しない
生かしてあげるということをしましょうよと
そこで盗むことをやめましょうよと
それから何でしたっけ？欲情な行為
あれいいわけないでしょう
かなりまずいでしょう
やっちゃうと不倫したりね
で やめます これはお釈迦様の言葉ではカンナンダンマンパジャヘイヤーし
カンナンダンマンというのは
このカンナっていうのはブラック
黒い生き方やめましょうと
イダガーミニアリエサワコパーナティパタンパハヤパーナティパータパティヴィラトホーティ
それで項目ごとにこの個人に教えていくんです
個人 聖者の弟子は殺生をやめて不殺生を実行する
このアリエサワコ聖者の弟子という単語を使うんだけど
それは宗教に引っ張られていない人なんです
理性で物事を考える人なんです
アリア 私は聖者と訳しますけど
アリアっていうのはかっこいいという意味なんですよ
ノーブル 優れた生き方
ちょっと優れた生き方
ノーブル的なノーブル
ご存知ですね  NBLいわゆる品格ある
生き方 これ だらしないことの正反対です
このノーブルな生き方をする人は
殺生をやめて 不殺生を実行するんだと
私は殺しませんよと言ってかっこつけますよ
誰も殺しませんよ 盗みませんよと
で  10項目 嘘をつかない
真理語る 噂は言わない
噂っていうのは この互い違い言葉
人を仲違いする言葉なんです
だから平和の言葉を喋ると
恐ろしい この野郎 馬鹿野郎とかね
こらーとか そういう失礼な言葉を使わない
粗悪語 美しい言葉を使うことになる
それから無駄話ではなくて
役に立つ言葉を語るとかね
これで 10項目に行く
それで頭がイカれたような欲と頭がイカれる怒りはやめる
欲はあるんだけど あ ほどほど怒っちゃいますけど
ほどほどに なんかもう管理できないぐらいもう激怒して
もうカッとなって人殺しにまでいくところまで精神的にイカれないところでコントロールする
それからものの見方をしっかりする
そこでステップツーに入ります
ステップツーに入る前にちょっと説明がありまして
この悪の 1 から 7 まで
いわゆる殺生から 無駄話まで
体の行為と言葉を戒めるんです
殺生は体でするでしょ
盗みは体でするでしょ
邪淫は体でやっているでしょ
この 3つやめれば体をコントロールしているんですね
殺生しない 盗まない 邪淫はやめる
3つだけ それで嘘をつかない
噂しない 粗悪語をしない
無駄話しない この 4つで言葉の管理
で  7つですね  8 異常欲
それから九瞋恚 十邪見から離れると心が落ち着くんです
健康な精神状態になるんです
気をつけてください 世の中の人間の精神状況が決して健康じゃないんです
そこで心を混乱させる妄想が減るんです
あの異常欲っていうのは妄想ですよ
瞋恚も妄想です 妄想するんですよ
あれが欲しいなとかね
車欲しいな でもポルシェがあればいいなとかね
100 万も持ってないくせに
でも思考は自由であるとね
それで喧嘩するんですよ
私には 1万しかないんだけど
なんでポルシェの夢見たら悪いんですかとかね
悪いんですよ  1万しか持ってないんだったら
おいしいご飯でも食いなさいよと
ポルシェ買うこと置いておいて
だからこれすごい危険
みんな勝手にやってます
漫画見たり だから仏教は一番気をつけるのはこの八九十なんです
心の制御 だから妄想減っちゃいますね
ほどほどやってますからね
欲はあるんだけど ほどほど
怒っちゃいますけど ほどほどにとか
理性は守ってますね 理性も飛んじゃう
飛んじゃいしまっちゃう
怒りはしません そこで心が落ち着いてくるんです
アリエサーコエーワンウィガタービッジョーウィガタビャーパードアサンモールホサンパジャーノパティススト
ここで意味はものすごく落ち着きますよと
自分の生き方は これでも生き方はできてるでしょ
心の中も穏やかで 社会に対する生き方も穏やかで
気づくこと 集中することができるようになる
妄想が減ったらどうなるのかというと
ああ 気分爽快です 笑顔が戻るんです
すごく楽になるんです
なんかすごく楽になって
大人しくなって はい ステップ３に行く
そこで妄想もなく減って
落ち着いた心になったら
慈しみの実践に入るんです
メッターサハガテーナチェーテサエーカンディサンパリッタービハレティ
これは経典でお釈迦様が語る慈悲の瞑想のやり方
ちょっと難しいんですけど
自分の心でメッター慈しみを作って
エーカンディサン一つの方向にその慈しみで触れてみるんです
例えば 私がこちらに立って
皆様が私の前にいるんですね
で 私が心の中で慈しみを作って
幸せであってほしいな
皆様方はと と思う 年末になったんだからね
みんな本当に楽しく 家族で仲良くプレゼント交換して
で ボーナスももらってもらうかどうかわかりませんだけどね
まあで このごろね 楽しく過ごしてほしいなと
で 私の目の前にいるこの方向ね
フランチャードレクションですね
このどんどんみんな私にも前にいる生命
みんな幸せでいてほしいと
私は心で触れてみようとするんです
私の心で で まあやってみればそんなに難しくないんですね
ちょっと幸せでいてねとかね
それだけ あ どうです 神様
本当に幸せでですかね
という感じで で 自分の気持ちをで生命に触れてみる
一つの方面を慈しみの気持ちで触れつつ住むのです
この住むのですというのは
実践を行いつつ 普通に生活するという意味なんです
だから決めてみましょう
今日から私は私の先方に
前の方向にいる人々に慈しみで触れてみました
で 決めてから 椅子だって普通に生活する
生活しながら 前に前に前に来る人々はみんな幸せでいてほしいな
みんな幸福であってほしいなとかね
みんな楽しく生活してほしいなとかね
みんな喧嘩してほしくないなとかね
仲良くしてほしいなとかね
後ろの人じゃなくて 前の方向に
やってみたら超面白いよ
忘れちゃったら困ります
だから朝起きたら前に誰がいるんでしょうか
と じゃあみんな幸せであってほしいとかね
自分がこうやって振り返ったりやっちゃいっす
でも前があるんだからね
みんな幸せであってほしいとかね
こうやって自分の前の方向に
どんな方向を見ても 慈しみで触れて触れて触れて
普通に生活してみる なんか偉そうなことをやらなくちゃいいんです
だからヴィハーティ生活するという言葉を使うんです
あの特別なんか変な宗教修行をやってるわけじゃないんです
普通に常識的な人間で
普通に仕事をして生きてみるんです
しかし 普通に仕事をして生きてみるんだけど
先方の自分の前の人々には
まあちょっと穏やかな顔で触れてみる
幸せで 幸せで 幸せで 幸せで
幸せで 幸せでっている
まあ普段誰だってやることですさ
こんにちはとかね 後の人に言わないでしょ
後の人は死んじゃってもいいとも思ってないんだけど
やっぱりこんにちは お元気ですか？って前の人に聞くでしょ
そのまま実践すれば それから 2つの方向
3つの方向  4つの方向にも広げてみるんです
増やします じゃあ前だけじゃなくて
後ろも 右側も左側もと
そこでなんで方向で取ったのかというと
この方向っていうのは面白いんですよ
あの あの 何でしたっけ？地平線で止まらないんですね
私の前はここまでですかね
どこまで？リミットがないんで
じゃああの地球 あの球体で考えて
地球の上に立っているんだからね
立って自分の前と言ったら宇宙の果てまで行くでしょ
リミットがないんです
だからこの方法を お釈迦様がいつでもこの方法で慈悲の瞑想を教えるんです
だから ちょっと私たちの取り方とは随分桁違い
巨大な取り方なんです
だから 皆様方も実践するぐらいそんな気持ちでやった方がいいかもしれませんよ
私のマイ方向っていうのは
前 前 前を見ると もう宇宙も飛ばしちゃってね
無限に行っちゃうんですね
ありとあらゆる生命がみんな幸せであってほしいと
一つの方向終わったら
では右の方向もやってみようかなとか
左の方向もやってみようよと
一つ方向を完了したらできます
じゃあ後ろにもやってみようと
それから下どうですかね
下方っていうのはまたリミットがないでしょ
また宇宙の果てまで行くんですね
じゃあ情報は？これまた宇宙の果てまで行っちゃうんです
そういうことで リミットがないことでこの瞑想になってます
ステップ３ イティ ウッダマドー ティリヤン サッバディ サッバタッターヤ サッバワンタン ロカン メッタサー
ガ テナ チェータサ ヴィプレーナ マハガテナ アッパ マーネーナ ヴェーレナ アッベ パジェナ パッティ パリットゥア ヴィハルティ
文章は長いんだけど 省略して意味書きます
このように 前後左右上下という六方にも
また横とかね 広げて広げて広げて
無限にこの気持ちを広げてタッチするんです
自分の心でタッチするんです
だからこのタッチできるところから始めた方がいいんです
だから私には今皆様が見えるんだから
皆様の心にタッチできますね
慈しみで 慈しみでタッチすると誰も嫌がらないんです
でなきゃケチするんです
だから男性が女性にね
どうですか？コーヒー一杯で断りますと
ではなくて じゃあまあおめでとうございます
まあなんとかなんとか年末なんとか言ったら
ありがとうございます
まあ受け取っちゃいますよ
でしょ コーヒー一杯どうです？って言ったら断りますけど
あのおめでとうございますとかね
ハッピーニューイヤーとか言ったら
ハッピーニューイヤーとまた返してくれますね
だから慈しみ 慈しみで触れると
もうみんな反対しないんで受けるんです
だからタッチできるんです
心のタッチ だからこれはまあやってみてほしいと
そこで一切の生命に障害なく壮大して触れるんです
これは常識的に理解できる精神状態じゃないんです
何の宗教も取り入れることなく
何の信仰も取り入れることなく
お釈迦様が心が極端に成長するのを教えているんです
これやってみればできることなんですよ
壮大した無量の慈しみの気持ち
怒りのない 審議のない気持ちを感じつつ生活する
そこで自分の心には何の隔たりも
何のわだかりもわだかまりも
何の障害もなく 生命たるものを幸せだと
いう気分でいるんですよ
だからこのタッチすることをちょっとやってみてください
そうすると あ これって結構いいなと感じるんです
一人の人を喜ばせてあげてみてください
自分がどれほど気持ちいいかと
で ステップ４に入ります
そこで結論に達するんです
ステップ４は 布施に効果なしなどの行為の結果を断言否定する宗教家がいる
もしもその教えがその通りであっても
私には問題ありません
と アパンナカタエマイハン
I have no problem
布施したっても意味がない
人を殺したっても何の罪もない
そんなこと正しいかもよ
でも I have no problem
本人がすごい具体的に拡大したリミットを超えたすごい心を持ってるんです
だから別にどうでもいいっていう感じです
それでも私は誰の迷惑にもならない生き方をしています
私の生き方は誰の迷惑にもなりませんよと
その教えが間違って 本当に生命に死後があるとしても OK です
構わない  I have no problem
例えば 死んじゃったら天国か地獄ですって言うでしょ？いいえ
死んじゃったら終わり
天国もない 地獄もないと言うでしょ
別にどちらでもいいんだよと
どうぞご自由にと なぜ？ I have no problem
私はどちらにでも OK だと
私は自分の生き方を見つかってますよと
私は今もすっごく穏やかで
ものすごく素晴らしい楽しい気持ちでいるんだよと
だって一人二人は喜ぶってすごい楽しいでしょ
これ 無数の生命の幸せを念じると
もうもう細胞に耐えられないくらい幸福を感じるんです
私は正しい生き方をしているので
死後必ず幸福になります
もし死後があったら必ず幸福になります
死後がなかったら それでも私は幸せです
教えは正であれ 否であれ
私の勝ちですと 宗教に関係なく勝ちを取るんです
ウベメッタカタッガホ
だから宗教通り正しくても
私は OK 私はこれ他宗教に対して同じことを言うでしょ
神様が最後の審判をやるときは
仏教徒は審判しないんです
だってこの連中は仏教だからね
アリ一匹も殺してないし
かえって全部アリ一匹でも私が作ったものだからね
だから私の祖先に対して敬意を持って生きてきたんだから
もうそのまま天国に行きなさいよと
捕まるのはキリスト教の方々
こっち来いよと お前ら一人一人調べなくちゃあかんやと
イスラム神はイスラム教であっても大丈夫です
仏教徒は審判なし もう天国に行くんです
大丈夫です だって生き方正しいんだから
何とも文句ないでしょ
アッラー神様がこの世界を創ったならば
我々はこの世界に対して慈しみで触れてますからね
幸福でありますようにと思ってるんだから
これこそ神を尊敬する生き方ないでしょ
自爆テロをやって神を守らなくちゃあかんやと思う人ほど神を冒涜するものがいるんですかね
だから この仏教の道っていうのは宗教ではないんだけど
どちらにしたっても勝ちなんです
神はアッラーでもイエホワでももう猿様でもいいんです
これは疑問が生じないスタンスですね
で ステップ５に行きます
じゃあステップ４もうまとめます
まずはあれ 暗い生き方をやめますね
重善重悪 重悪やめて重善を行う
これはもうスタート 生命を殺しながら悩めないで生きられるということはありえないでしょ
盗人やりながら私は吾輩は安心だと言えないでしょうに
だから生き方から始めて
それから慈悲の瞑想をするんです
誰に文句言えないんです
だから重善重悪は宗教ではありません
慈悲の瞑想は宗教ではありません
何の信仰も入ってないんです
そこでどうなるかというと
自分が完璧に生きているんだということでしょ
疑問なく完璧に生きている
いわゆるノープロブレムと生き方なんですね
ノープロブレム 悩みない
心配ない生き方 困らない
神社のことで 教会のことで
お寺のことで もう別に困らないという
そこで困らないというと
なんとなくなんか気分が良くなってくるんですよ
これ 慈悲をちょっとやってみると
もう最高の中からものすごくなんか気分が良くなってくるんです
心の中に生まれるすごい悪いエネルギーあるでしょ
妄想すると これはないんです
タッサ パーモッジャン ジャーティ
この日本語の単語はないんだから
このパーリ語でいわゆるパーモッジャっていうのは
なんとなく気分がいいっていうことでね
これでノープロブレム
生き方見つかった人には気分がいいんです
退出する教えと関係なく
自分が勝利をすると知っているので
知るので楽しみを感じるという意味ですね
パムディ ダッサ ピーティ ジャーティ
気分が良くなってくると
なおさらなんか喜びの波動が
楽しみの波動がじわじわじわじわ生まれてくるんです
中から ピーティ マナッサ カーヨー パッサン ベティ
で 体の中からね あの普通ノーバッカシだから
皆様の場合は頭の上から感じるかもしれません
慈悲の瞑想するとそうでもないんです
体の中から 中心点から喜びがずっと広がっていくんです
で 体全部を支配してしてしまうんです
すごく安らぎの波動が
そこでこうやってじーっと体から喜びの安らぎの波動が広げてしまったら
カーヨー パッサン ベティ
この肉体がものすごく軽くなっちゃうんです
肉体があるかないかわからないぐらい軽くなってしまうんです
心に喜びがあると体が軽くなります
これは教案と言いますね
パッサッド カーヨー スカン ウェーデーティ
この体 すごく楽になっちゃうとさらに楽ですよ
体なんか なんかもう風船みたいに綿でできているような感じで
スポンジでできているような感じで
すごい軽い   そういうのはしっかり体験できるようになります
で 今体重いでしょ？硬いでしょ？痛いでしょ
体がなんかどんどんどんどん軽くなってくるとどうですかね
重さが減って減って 肉体がなんかあるかないかもわからないぐらい体中このこの軽さを感じるんですね
体に教案があるとさらに楽になります
これはの 脳 体 心の成長を心の体という順番でお釈迦様が語られているんです
これは普通脳の開発でもありますけど
順番違います 仏教でまず心から始めてくださいと
心をちゃんと慈悲の実践すると
脳がそれ知って配線してくれるんです
脳の配線出来上がっちゃうと
もう体も軽くなってきます
病気もなくなっちゃう
気分が良くなっていくんです
仏教は心からスタートするんです
脳からスタートしないんです
で 最後の最後だと思います
またあります  5番目のステップですね
月のチッタンサマーディエティ
ここまでものすごく気絶感感じて
喜びを感じて 体も心も軽くて
脳も完璧に配線出来上がっていると
心が勝手にサマーディに入るんです
禅定が生まれるんです
楽からサマーディが生まれるんです
楽になった心で心はサマーディに達します
禅定に達します アヤンコーカーミニガーミニ
ダンマサマーディコジ
これはダンマサマーディと言うんだよと
この順番で宗教はなし
しかしちゃんと経験させるんです
安らぎを タトラ チェトゥアンチッタサマーディンパティラベイアーシ
そこでダンマサマーディっていうのは
このシステム教えですね
それでこのポータリーさんがそれからやらなくちゃいけないんでしょ
自分でやったらチッタサマーディなんです
あ こういう方法ですね
宗教から自由 宗教から解放される
悩みから解放される 頭デッカチ状態とか解放される
ってわかることはダンマサマーディ
やってみたらチッタサマーディ
経験したらチッタサマーディ
そこであなたは心のサマーディを体験するのですというところで
この経典が終わるんです
いかがでしょうか で あの宗教の哲学は難しかったんで
私もあんまり長く説明しちゃうと長くなるんだから飛ばしましたけど
世の中の宗教はどうでもいいんですよ
宗教から自由になってください
もう宗教とはレリジアンでしょ
束縛って意味でしょ いわゆる私たちは奴隷にするんです
自由にならなくちゃいけない
自由になる方法っていうのは
宗教はどうでもいいんだから
私は摂取しませんよと
あんた勝手なこと何言ったっても
どうぞご自由にと 私は殺しません
盗みませんと いうふうに十善十悪を実況して
それから慈悲の実践する
それで終わり  ブッダの教えにまたさらに納得したら
智慧の開発というもう一つプログラムありますけどね
そういうことで ダンマサマーディ
チッタサマーディという 2つの用語で
いかに人間があらゆる宗教やら哲学から心を解放して
極端な無限の自由を獲得するのかということと書かれています
はい 以上です はい そういうことで
このサンガ2回のね サラートの輪廻のガーミニサンゲッの 13番目の経典ポータリー経典の省略した説明です
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
えーと 若干時間ございますので
もし質問ある方いらっしゃいましたら
マイクを持って回しますので挙手いただけますでしょうか
...ちょっと私も目があまり良くないんですけど
誰もいらっしゃらないですよね
あ はい 少々お待ちください
えーと すみません 講演とはちょっと関係ないんですけれども
年末年始にインドの仏跡にちょっと行ってくる予定があるんですが
この際 何 どういうことに気をつけたらいいかとか
何かアドバイスがあったらいただければと思うんですが
よろしくお願いいたします
先生の本は読んでますけれども
あの ものを買う人に気をつけてください
あの あの あの服とかなんとか見てね
この人々はすごく貧しくて貧乏でかわいそうやとか思わない方が無難です
あれは職業です あのギルドがあるんで
あの なんて言いますか
この物乞いビルドがあって
みんないろいろ取ってあちらにあげるんです
別にあげてはいけませんではなくて
気をつけるということですね
それから  こういう人類の偉大なる人
時代を超えた人が歩いたところ
いたところを見て楽しんだ方がいいんじゃないんですかね
仏跡巡るならば そこをすごい感じることができると思います
で 不思議なところ お釈迦様が回ったところはいつだって平和なんです
あのチョイチョフネイティビティというイスラエルにある
イエス様が生まれたところとかね
ずっと殺し合いやってますけどもね
お釈迦様が悟り開かれたところ
生まれたところ すごい幸せ
平和なんです これ感じたら感じた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
はい 以上だけです  えーと
他の方どなたか あ ではありがとうございます
カサリと申します あの
老いと苦しみっていうのは人間に付きついてくると思うんですけど
今説明していただいたことっていうのは
やっぱり自分が老いと苦しみで体が苦しめられている中でも
それは実現できるものでしょうか
あと あの 仏教は真理に基づいてつながっていると思うんですが
真理だけで答えが出せるものでしょうか？それとも最後にやっぱり宗教としての信仰みたいのを働かせないと
それにたどり着けないものでしょうか
はい まあ信仰なんかいらないと思いますけど
別に自分で自分の生き方を管理すればいいでしょうに
老いることは誰でも老いちゃうし
それでも心ですごく安らぎを感じていられるいられるでしょうに
生命のこと至死で生きていけるものが幸せでありますようにと
恨みを捨てて排除して
憎しみを排除して それから自分の肉体に対するこの執着
年取りたくない 老いたくないとかね
それも排除して すっごく柔らかな心でいられるでしょうに
これは体感できるでしょうに
この狭いリミットでいる心がね
私の肉体 私の肉体とかね
肉体にだけに迫っている
この心をね 破っちゃいましょう
自分が生命が幸せでありますようにという気持ちで生きているものだと
それだったら心配いらないんでしょ？ただ
医者があのね あんたたとあと 2週間だよと言われたって
別にどうってことないですよ
私はノープロブレムでしょ
私の生き方では何も心配することはありませんと
だから I have no problem といういいやり方
言えるようになってほしい I
have no problem
プロブレムというのは
まあ悩んだりすることは後悔ですね
お釈迦様はこのお坊さんたちがね
ちょっと最後に臨死状態になったら行って質問するのは
あんた後悔すること何かある？それだけなんです Do
you have anything to worry on? って
そしたら本人がちょっとわからなくなったら
お釈迦様は具体的に君ちゃんと戒律を守った？はいはい
お釈迦様 戒律はもうやりました
うん で それで慈悲の瞑想とかなんだらかんだら
それなりにやりました
頑張ってやりましたと
で まだ悟ってないならば
それだったら喜びなさいよ
あんたはしっかりしたでしょうにと言って
お釈迦様はその最後の瞬間ですごく褒めてあげるんです
それですごく解脱に達するんです
そういうことで あの 後悔することはないんだぞと
ノープロブレムというね
いう生き方 実現してみましょうよ
そんなに難しいことじゃないと思います
で 宗教なんかは まあ正直なところで要りません
信仰っていうのは この弱い者の藁にすがることで
泳げるんだったら自分で泳げと
私たちは泳げる人間作りたいんです
だってみんな人間だからね
できるはずなんです 一部の人間に宗教が必要で
一部の人間に宗教はいらないっていうのはね
すごい失礼な言葉なんです
だから私はあえて失言で宗教はいるのは原始人やと
石器時代の人間やというのが私の表現で
それは計画的な失言なんです
なぜかというと 皆様方は原始人じゃないんだから
文化人だから 教育を受けているんだから
科学知ってるんだから
IT 時代に来てるんだから
だから馬鹿にしてるんです
そういうわけで まあ最終答えは生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
このモットーで生きる人に何か言いたい文句でもありますかと
神様でも誰でもいいんです
ある女性の方が精神的にものすごく病気で
病気になったのはカトリック教の方で
神父さんがどんどんどんどん洗脳して洗脳してね
ひどい病気にさせちゃって
いい信者さん作っちゃったんですね
そこで病気で治療を受けなくちゃいけない
薬を飲まなくちゃいけない
いろいろあったところで
なんかわけわからないんだけど
私のところに来てね 私を見たら
信仰は私に関係ないんだから
この人は心が病気で これ治ってあげようと言って
慈悲の瞑想のやり方とかいろいろ教えてあげて
本人もやってみたんですね
やったら心が治ったんですね
普通の常識の明るい人間になっちゃったんですね
明るい人間になった途端
もう 20年も 30年も付き合ってる神父さんがいる
横浜の誰かのとんでもない人なんですけどね
まあ正式的な神父ですけど
詐欺師ですからね で 私に聞いたんですよ
自分 30 年もお世話になっていますから
これはどうそう どうそう付き合ってくださいと
別にあなたに私は宗教を教えていないんだよと
そしたら本人が言って
実は神父様 私はこういう瞑想をやってまいったら
また脅して あなたは世にある極端な罪を犯したんだと
神を冒涜したんだと って怯えて私にも電話あったんですけど
私はこの女性にしゃべるんじゃなくて
横浜まで行って あの神父を首から絞めなくちゃあかんやと
で 信仰はくったくた壊さなくちゃあかんと思ったんですけど
私にはもう５分で十分です ５
分で十分です 私から見れば
なんて残酷な失礼なことをしたのかいということなんです
なんであの人に生命を慈しむことできないのかと
だから私も聖書はちゃんと読んでいるし
知っているし 勉強もしているし
で 何学でしたっけ？それも知っているし
だから聞きたかったのは
あなたは証明しなさい
私はすべての生命を慈しみます
いわゆるすべての生命を愛しますという一言葉は
どのように聖書に反する教えでしょうかと
だからお前でしょうと
神を否定しているのはと言いたかったんですけど
まあいらん喧嘩だから行けなかったんですね
行かなかったんです しかし
彼女がまた病気になったんです
で 私もその人のことはもうどうしようもないし
そこは自分の責任でしたからね
神父さんそう言っても
これはまあ気持ちいいんでしょうと理解すれば
そこまでなかったしね
だからそういう風に この
まあ将来は病院で終生する人だったらね
精神的に かわいそうですけど
まあいまだに覚えてるんで
随分前の話ね もう 15年もっと前の話なんですけどね
だから我々は理性を保ちましょうよ
信仰っていうのは理性を潰すんですよ
自分で判断する それを奪ったら
そこは洗脳なんです それだけ誰にも負けないでください
自分の人生を自分で判断してください
簡単です あの十悪をやめてください
それだけ 自分の自分で判断して
だってできるでしょ？盗むことはいい
みんな知ってるよ そういうこと
悪いと だから十悪やめても自分で判断してやめているんです
そういうことで 人間が決して自分にある
この判断できる能力だけはね
壊さないでください これは大変なことになります
そういうことで 結論は宗教は要りません
誰だって幸せになれます
誰だって究極に幸せになります
以上です  はい それではそろそろお時間となりましたので
講演会の方を終了したいと思います
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文をお唱えして終了したいと思いますので
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に来拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に生れますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンビキヨイバンジャントゥサンバローゴウヴィナッサトゥマーテーバートワンタラーヨスケリーガーユコーバガ
バウトサッブマンディランラックアントゥサンバデーヴァタサンバブンダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマヌバーヴェーナサッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダースッティマヴァントゥテー
アビワダナシーリッサディッチャンヴァッダパジャイノーチャッターロダンマーヴァッダンティアーユワンノースカンバラン
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
では どうもありがとうございます